let's see if we can stumble our way to a
another logarithm property so let's say
that oh I don't know let's say that the
log base X of a is equal to B right
that's the same thing as saying that is
the exact same thing as saying that X to
the B is equal to a fair enough so what
I want to do is experiment what happens
if I multiply this this expression by
another variable let's call it C right
so I'm going to multiply both sides of
this equation times C now let's switch
colors just to keep things interesting
that's not an X that's a ch4 I just to a
dot instead times C right so I'm gonna
multiply both sides this equation times
C so I get C C times log base X of a is
equal to multiply both sides the
equation right is equal to B times C
fair enough I think you realize I have
not done anything profound just yet
let's go back we said that this is the
same thing as this so let's let's
experiment with something let's raise
this side to the power C so I'm going to
raise this side to the power C that's a
kind of a caret and when you type
exponents that's what you would use a
carrot right so I'm going to raise it to
the power C so then this side is X to
the B to the C power is equal to a to
the C right all right it hasn't raised
both sides of this equation to the C
power and what do we know about what do
we know about when you raise something
to an exponent and you raise that whole
thing to another exponent what happens
to the exponents well that's that's just
an exponent rule and you just multiply
those two exponents so this just becomes
this just implies that X to the B C is
equal to a C
what can we do now well I don't know
let's take the logarithm of both sides
okay or let's just write this let's not
take the logarithm of both sides let's
write this as a logarithm expression we
know that X to the BC is equal to a to
the C well that's the exact same thing
as saying that the logarithm base X of a
to the C right logarithm base X of a to
C is equal to BC correct because it all
I did is I rewrote this as a logarithm
expression and I think now you realize
that something interesting has happened
that BC this BC well of course it's the
same thing as this BC right so this
expression must be equal to this
expression and I think we have another
logarithm property that if I have some
kind of coefficient in front of the
logarithm I'm multiplying the logarithm
so if I have C klog o'clock base X of a
but that's C times the logarithm base X
of a that equals the log base X of a to
the C so you could take this coefficient
instead make it an exponent on on the
term inside the logarithm that is
another logarithm property so let's
review what we know so far about
logarithms we know we know that if I
write let me let me use a different let
me say if I write well let me just
letters I've been using C times
logarithm base X of a is equal to
logarithm base X of a to the C we know
that and we know we just learned that
logarithm base X of a plus logarithm
base X so B is equal to the logarithm
base
X of a times B now let me ask you a
question
what happens if instead of a positive
sign here we put a negative sign well
you could probably figure it out
yourself but we could do that same exact
proof that we did in the beginning but
in this time we will we'll set it up
with a negative so if I said that let's
just say that log base X of a is equal
to L let's say that log base X of B is
equal to M and let's say that let's say
that log base X of a divided by B is
equal to n right now let's how could we
write all of these expressions as
exponents well this just says that X to
the L is equal to a alright let me let
me switch colors I keeps it interesting
this is just saying that X to the M is
equal to B and this is just saying that
X to the N is equal to a over B right so
what can we do here well what hot was
another way of writing a over B well
that's that's just the same thing as
writing X to the L because that's a X to
the L over X to the M that's B right and
this we know from our exponent rules
right it's just you could write this
could also be written as X to the L X to
the negative M right or that also equals
x to the L minus M so what do we know we
know that X to the N is equal to X to
the L minus M right X to the N is equal
to X to the L minus M those equally
gender I just made a big equal chain
here so we know that n is
equal to L - M what does that do for us
well what's another way of writing n I'm
going to do it up here because I think
we have stumbled upon another logarithm
rule what's another way of writing n I
did it right here this is another way of
writing n right
so logarithm logarithm base X of a over
B this is an x over here is equal to L L
is this right here write log base X of a
is equal to L the log base X of a minus
M I wrote em right here that's log base
X of B log base X of B there you go I
probably didn't have to prove it you
could apply you try it out with tried it
out with you know dividing it putting or
whatever but and you now are hopefully
satisfied that we have this new
logarithm property right there I have
one more logarithm property to show you
but I don't think I have time to show it
in this video so I will do it in the
next video
I'll see you soon